hello folks how's everybody doing hope
you're doing fine today I would not be
talking a little bit about extinction
the reason I were gonna talk about
extinction as I said last week or last
night that if one three people wanted to
talk about the subject but I'll cover it
in a little more detail than I did the
other day and several people came back
saying yeah they want to hear a little
bit about extinction
so let's see what we have to say about
extinction well the first thing we need
to learn about extinction is that the
list of movies dealing with
end-of-the-world scenarios has gone up
in fact exponentially I guess in this in
the latter half of the second ascent of
the 20th century and here you see some
movies that were made in the 60s and 70s
there's maybe you know what 20 to 30
movies per year and this is the list now
in this past decade a hundred movies
okay so apparently people are it's it's
a subject that that people like a lot
quite a bit today or at least are
interested in I guess everybody's
concerned about their future or or
there's maybe a sense maybe a sense that
things are not quite right that this is
a different moment in history a type of
moment in history then what we had in
the past and that's that's something for
you to ponder if we're in a different
situation today than we were in the you
know under 200 500 years ago you know
you talked about people who who talked
about the first millennium that it was
going to be the end of the world because
Jesus was coming or whatever you had all
these
rather just predict things or interpret
the Bible and it never happened
and you've had also all kinds of
diseases and people thought it was the
end of the world never happened and so
these predictions never came true but
are we in a different situation today
can we extrapolate the past to our days
that's going to be in the background ok
that's going part of the topic anyways
I'm gonna start with comments because
some people made a couple comments I
think that's a good way of introducing
the subject one person put this comment
not related really to extinction but I
put this as an example of how not to
make a comment ok this person says your
choice you you choose when ordinary
language matters and when it does not
and he put that for a video and you know
I have a problem with that because I
mean I don't know what he's talking
about
and I don't even know why people put
some stale comments if you don't put a
comment put a decent comment like you
know you want to discuss something or or
you say what's wrong with what I said
here I have no idea you know I don't
know what he's referring to make it in
his little mind he thought that he was
offended by what was written and or said
and and just vented his frustration
that's what it sounds like nothing more
than that I don't even know why they
spend time putting one-liners you know
don't they have anything better to do ok
another person put a comment I think
yesterday or today I remember he says
now related to the subject matter at
hand says after money will go away I had
to edit this a little bit
some people will organize some sort of
currency or will trade with each other
without money like American Indians
that's a typical comment that I receive
with respect to extinction people think
that we're gonna go into bartering a lot
of the narco caps anarcho-capitalists I
call narco caps
they have this idea that somehow we're
going to go into bartering where you
know everybody does his own thing with
without the intervention of government
so you sell your own things in your
local region or whatever and the economy
is handled separate from government we
don't need governor anymore that's why
they're called a narco yeah so yeah some
people believe that we're just going to
trade green money for brown money and
yeah I got a lot to say about that but
right now it's not the time for that I
prefer a comment a little more elaborate
coming I think it was this one so those
issues with Bill extinction Bill's
extinction and this fella says we have a
lot of land and resources to feed a lot
of people you know billions of people
there are parts of the earth that are
not populated yet and we still have land
to be to develop he puts his number
point number to the past causes of
extinctions cannot be extrapolated to to
the future or not necessarily to us 90
humans he says that genetic diversity
engineering new genetic diversity we're
gonna increase our genetic diversity
through yes engineering meat methods if
the economy collapses humanity still
will survive because we've already had
this situation at the past where we had
Wars and diseases and we overcame all
these obstacles he believes that the
future humanity lies in space we for
this we need to change our physical form
we will go out into space and he he says
he's uh as a result of that more
optimistic because he believes that
we're gonna survive all the way into the
next century at least okay and that
anyways the extinction is difficult to
predict okay so why did I put this
comment there I put it there because
it's typical of what I always get
yeah I usually get these types of
comments from people who do not
subscribe to the theory and I want to
make sure that you understand very
clearly that most of the people I would
say that the rational scientific method
are SM we have a group in facebook you
can join if you're interested they do
not subscribe to the extinction theory
they like the a lot of them like the
rope Marlin but they do not subscribe to
the extinction theory okay and it's up
there for people to discuss but not
everybody likes it okay okay so that in
a nutshell is the issue but what is the
problem with this individuals comment
and the problem I see with 99% of the
comments out there and I'll put that in
the description everybody is an expert
in economics everybody is an expert in
politics everybody's an expert in their
own opinions no doubt about that know
what I have yet to find someone who's an
expert in extinction everybody's an
expert in human extinction they
specialize in human extinction but no
one is an expert in extinction no one
can tell me anything about extinction
nobody wants to talk about extinction
see look at that I'll put this comment
back again okay what do you see this
fellow telling me how the dinosaurs died
or how the permian synapses died or
Triassic article SARS or whatever I
don't see it in there you know he goes
directly into humans he he's got a big
opinion on how humans will survive
anything that's thrown at him but nobody
but he can't tell me.how past species
died and this is the problem with just
about everybody who comes and criticizes
in the extinction Theory everybody's an
expert in politics and economics and
they just want to talk humans they're
not interested in animals okay
so what can I that say you know I've got
an option I can delete all comments that
do not start by stating how animals in
the past died if the guy just skips over
then wants to jump into human extinction
maybe I should delete those comments of
course you know I'm not interested in
doing that I'm just saying maybe that's
what I should do right so this is this
is a this is what I suggest here okay
there it is I think people should start
at extinction
101 okay and that means that they have
to tell the world the audience they
should explain a mechanism of extinction
right and especially one that's already
happened of the animals of the things we
know are in the rock we've got all these
different bones in there they don't
exist anymore so we have to believe that
they became extinct we've had six
hundred million years apparently right
or what the record shows of life here on
earth at least of living entities of
animals probably even longer for plants
and we have to explain those extinction
what happened to those animals and if
you cannot explain that then you cannot
talk about human extinction because you
are an ignoramus
you know nothing about extinction you
haven't taken extinction 101 and the
only thing you got explained here is
selectivity you're gonna tell me in a
you know your mechanism in your theory
how mother nature selects one species
and leaves the others alive or a group
of species and leaves another group of
species alive that's what you got to
tell the audience audience wants to hear
your mechanism not your opinion about
why humans are not going to die okay and
then if you pass that first step and you
finished extinction 101 with flying
colors and you can explain selectivity
rights specifically right a mother
nature
selects a species or a group of species
now we can move on to the extinction of
human now you can tell me all you want
about your economic expertise and your
political expertise okay and yeah so you
can go to extinction 102 now you need a
prerequisite extinction 101 you can talk
about human extinction if you want to
talk there don't tell me your opinion
about you know how you don't think it's
gonna we're gonna die because history
showed us and then first you tell me
whether humans are ever going to die is
our species eternal are we going to live
billions trillions of years are we now
live quadrillions are we going to live
forever okay that's the first question
you gonna answer okay and that's a yes
or no type of question then you tell me
why not I mean if you don't think you
know you got to try either they you live
forever you don't live forever right
and if you don't think we're not going
to look forever you know sorry if you
think we're going to live forever you
might say well you know we're gonna go
to the Stars or or whatever you know you
tell me your theory and if if so if you
believe that we're we're gonna die then
you gotta have a foolproof mechanism for
our extinction and please don't tell me
we're going to throw the Dukes at each
other because that's easily destroyed we
just don't do it you just don't throw
the noose at each other like we haven't
you know at least in sportsbook right so
yeah it's very simple to the Australian
argument about nuclear weapons it's also
easy to destroy an argument about
disease we can locate any virus any
bacteria under the microscope and kill
it before it expands we have that
technology so you know you're gonna be
limited in your in your options
I need a foolproof mechanism yeah and if
if you don't have a foolproof method
mechanism for the extinction of the
human race you can't talk about it
of the human race now if you think we're
going to live forever well you don't
have to explain anything do you but you
have to explain you know how we're gonna
avoid extinction in that case okay so
it's easy to talk and give your opinion
because you don't like a theory of
extinction and by the way it's never a
popular theory you know it's fighting
against the the stream no matter how you
phrase that nobody likes to be told that
he's got six months to live you know
it's it's never going to be popular with
a patient okay and so you know people
don't like the extinctions yeah on the
one hand they're attracted to the notion
like you can see in the number of movies
that have been made but on the other
hand you know people don't like the fact
that there's no future that there's no
hope they don't like that nobody likes
that and they would rather as I say
prove themselves and think you know
they're on the Titanic and they have
this hope or they just fell off an
airplane and they think they were
without a parachute and they think that
maybe there was a they fall into some
soft spot down there on the ground and
that's wishful thinking okay and this is
more or less the same thing extinction
is guaranteed as far as I'm concerned
and so those people who say that will
not live forever they're gonna have a
lot of explaining to do of those who
think that we're going to become extinct
by some other means that that I'm
proposing in this channel they better
have a good theory of extinction I'd
love to tear it to pieces okay okay
anyways so where do we go from here well
we've had like I said you know a lot of
people deal with like extinction to you
one of the most well the most popular
theory is the dinosaur extinction and
that happened about 65 million years ago
people like it because all these big
animals gigantic animals roam the earth
and then they vanished
and so of course people say well huh
what happened to them you know they were
the rulers of the planets here we were
we were tiny mammals like little mice
running around their feet they probably
even pay attention to us we were like
ants are to us you know they're our feet
we don't even pay attention to ants and
maybe we're mammals well had the similar
relationship to dinosaurs and so how do
these big animals disappear and when you
look at the room when you do a little
research I've been doing research over
20 years on this subject so I can tell
you a little bit about it and what you
find out there is that no one has the
slightest clue I have no respect for any
paleontologist on earth okay
that's my starting point after doing
research I have no respect for any
paleontologist on earth all their
theories 100 50 percent of them are
garbage nonsense
idiocy that's my starting point that's
what I've learned
after 20 years of research into into
extinction theories and what they do is
politics here you have a case ok this is
uh I think I got this from Wikipedia and
it says in March 2010 international
panel 41 Sciences we viewed twenty years
of scientific literature and endorsed
the asteroid hypothesis and this
asteroid hypothesis has to do with an
asteroid hitting the earth okay and
causing the extinction of the dinosaurs
that was the trigger okay and here what
these people did was just research bunch
of paper said oh yeah we believe it
that's what happened case closes that's
it
and that's politics that shall be their
religion down your throat that's what
that's what that amounts to that's just
propaganda it's got nothing to do with a
mechanism okay when we get into
mechanism we find out that the answer it
has many many problems okay and so
what's the overall idea is the asteroid
hidden
car that in Rock containing so far much
of which was vaporized thereby injecting
sulfuric acid aerosols into the
stratosphere
okay would have caused acid rain that's
how the animals in the water especially
the reptiles the big reptiles like the
Mosasaurus that's how those became
extinct there was too much acidity in
the waters and you wonder why the
acidity didn't kill all the other
animals well they had special protection
against acidity is that what it was okay
and so they get all this stuff no were
they getting this asteroid and this this
nonsense they get it from these fellows
they wrote a seminal paper 1980 the
average lewis and his son Walter Alvarez
who was supposedly a geologist and they
came up with this this theory okay that
there was an extraterrestrial cause for
the KT extinction the
cretaceous-tertiary years no okay that's
where they started with all this and
it's important to know that Alvarez was
a Nobel Prize winner he was a Nobel
Prize winner not because he did anything
special as none of these people are he
it was just tied to the US military and
so he got his Nobel in through his
connections and then used his Nobel
Prize essentially his fame and fortune
to back that of his son the idea that
his son had for the extinction of the
dinosaurs since he was a geologist he
says oh you know maybe we look at the
later iridium I that's dated to about 65
million years ago what we can show that
an asteroid hit the earth because you
know there's no not so much iridium here
on earth but here we have this layer
apparently throughout the earth and that
could have been caused by an asteroid
which typically have high
percentage of uranium down here on earth
so they went in there and you know as a
so-called physicist mathematical
physicists that Albert was he went in
they calculated the size of the monster
that could have hit the earth and they
came up with this theory yeah that it
was all triggered by you know an
asteroid but an extraterrestrial cause
now catastrophic theories have been
around for quite a while in fact
Albertus wasn't the first one to come up
with that here we have let's see if I
can find it here max the Logan fells
1956 he came up with the same theory
before the Alvarez's I mean he already
had this mechanism of an
extraterrestrial cause okay in fact uh
in in the in the paper that written by
the Alvarez
they mentioned lovin thumbs okay and was
lob and tells the first one no no in
fact before him fact 200 years before
them this is the father father of
paleontology his name was George Cuvier
french guy and this is from a paper that
was written out there published in the
early 1800 georges cuvier
interpreted the sequence fossil found us
in rocks of the Paris Basin to represent
a series of catastrophic extinction
events big word catastrophic this marked
the beginning of the catastrophic school
of biological changes and a little
earlier before him french scientist
pierre their mouth parties
in 1742 argued that impacts by comets on
the earth have caused extinctions by
modifying the atmosphere and oceans
present-day scenarios are based on this
same essential concept so yeah what's
the issue the issue is that all these
people
saying well something happened
geologically suddenly sometime in the
past and a bunch of species were wiped
out what could it be
what's got to be at Astra feet and the
first thing everybody says is they look
up in the sky in this era it came out of
the sky right and that's what we have
today we have all these extinction
theories most of them have to do with a
space and guess who's behind all that
stuff because it's in their best
interest
and that's Naza NASA obviously loves
extinction theories involving extra to
rest your causes because you know that
puts them in the spotlight and says hey
you know we're the guys who who can tell
you what's up there because we have the
telescope so you have all this stuff
that we control and you know if an
asteroid comes our way and starts you
know we see that it's big and it's going
to hit the earth well we can at least
warn you we have the early warning you
gotta pay attention to us because we've
delicate the technology to detect it and
then I don't know maybe they take a nuke
up there and they nuke the thing you
know there's there's a couple movies on
that subject in fact where they blow up
an asteroid that's about it hit the
earth so not something is very important
suddenly because you know they have all
these theories okay after terrestrial
theories extraterrestrial causes for
extinction and you know I showed the
other day you know this is what they
have in mind they where is it here this
one they have this notion where the
earth was hit by an asteroid okay and
because of that caused all kinds of
fires there was an explosion caused
fires all around the earth and what
happened was you know the whole earth
was essentially the surface of the earth
according to these people was completely
destroyed all plants and animals
everything died as you can see you know
no one can survive so much fire the
earth was loved as a cinder yeah and
this is the notion that they'd like to
put out there yeah they have all this
fire and brimstone raining down on the
dinosaurs supposedly everything was
destroyed
plants and animals and that's the fire
brimstone version okay that you see
there yeah oh this brimstone raining
down on the poor animals burning them to
death
that's the fire version then you have
the other versions supposedly caused by
the same asteroid which is the water
world version you have the whole world
turned into water okay there's no land
available the water simply and go over
the land and just drown all the animals
which are running for their lives in
vain right and so you have this water
rule then you have the fire and
brimstone version it's a lot of fun
because all these people come up with
all these irrational theories on on how
the dinosaurs may have disappeared why
are they irrational well because these
people are saying that the entire Earth
was flooded or burned that no plant or
animal survived
that's essentially what these people are
saying and then in there they they
introduce the fact that yeah the mammals
did survive because they hid inside the
mountains or whatever and started eating
the treatise the that that matter that
plants and dead dead animals whatever
they ate and that's how they survived so
so they have all these contradictions on
the one hand they say look all plant
life was destroyed and the animals that
survived who knows how they survived so
much fire brimstone and waters flooding
they survived eating the critters until
the God decided to make plants and I
guess some animals back again I don't
know
so yeah they have irrational theories
and when you look at the study that was
made after four years by a group of
people this was a massive project by
several universities and think tanks and
you can see it here
there is no indication that all plant
life ever disappeared on earth after it
started saying the camp you know
Precambrian whenever it started never
has all life died on earth okay so all
this nonsense about fire burning the
entire surface of the earth or flooding
completely the surface of the earth it
is nonsense total nonsense the
Cretaceous terrestrial revolution chart
shows exactly what happened what
happened was that the flowering plants
muscled aside the conifers which is what
the dinosaurs ate this was a completely
a food problem okay that's gonna be my
argument okay for extinction and of
course all those people who think
differently again all they have to do is
put a theory that we can sink our teeth
into okay some mechanism don't tell me
how man is gonna survive and why
economics is not gonna kill them why
food will not kill them we don't want to
hear any of that
keep your nonsense to yourself tell me
tell the crowd tell the audience okay
how the animals in the past died if you
have no theory for animals in the past
you know nothing about extinction much
less can you know about human extinction
okay so we got to start an extinction
not at human extinction and I don't know
how to drive that home that point home
okay
okay was that the only catastrophe well
here we have with you here here is the
summary of catastrophes that have been
proposed proposed over time for the
Cretaceous the asteroid for permeance
the number one has the volcano some
people also proposed asteroid and for
the Ordovician one is rising again
because of NASA is that gamma rays from
a nearby supernova wiped out the species
okay
so that's what we have today we have
just catastrophic theories because
can't think of any other way that plant
life could disappear or an animal life
for that matter okay and the interesting
thing about some of these theories is
that this asteroid was very intelligent
we have an intelligent asteroid see the
Astron do selectivity chronologically
what I call chronological selectivity it
was able to wipe out the species that
had been around for a long time and
after all the new species and that
happened in every extinction the volcano
was a the Permian the Siberian traps
that was an intelligent volcano also she
had wiped out the old species and left
the new species intact both on land and
in the sea yeah these are very
interested in very smart acts of God all
these asteroids and volcanoes they they
are able to select chronologically and
when you do the study you find out that
that is the case what died were the old
species and what survived were the new
species why because they belonged to
different food chains which clearly
shows that it's not an extraterrestrial
cause or some kind of catastrophic
accidents such as volcanoes or methane
coming out of the sea or anoxia all that
other nonsense idiocy that all the
paleontologists have come up to until
today right so yeah anyone who's got a
theory of extinction I'd love to hear it
and it better be none of the ones that
are out there okay
I think I can easily criticize it okay
here's the Permian extinction just this
happened about 252 million years ago
this is from the Wikipedia and again
what do you see potential causes include
meteor impact events massive volcanic
eruptions and that's the primary one
climate change why climate change
because it's on everybody's
today that's why climate changes there
everybody's thinking about climate
change like if climate did anything for
extinction underwater methane yeah
that's another one that's very strong
suppose the some gases leaked out of the
surface of the sea yeah and what do the
experts say that's you would say well
that's the Wikipedia no no here's the
experts okay these are the people who
investigate the Permian extinction you
see their comments there this is comes
out of a National Geographic article
that summarizes sentencing with what we
know today for sure okay it's not easy
to kill so many species as Doug Irwin a
Smithsonian Institution paleontologist
hi I like the fact that they use these
big word paleontologists the guys never
taken extinction 101 it had to be
something catastrophic yeah of course
an enormous asteroid impact is the prime
suspect of Gregory right Alec a
geologist at University of Orion other
Permian detective suspected killer whose
DUP from the sea Paul rig no and Richard
butcher of the University of Leeds
reported the first evidence of oxygen
depletion or anoxia in rocks that formed
under shallow water at the time of the
extinction we no suspects that the
entire sea may have stagnated in Permian
times Permian oceans also might have
been poisoned with co2 according to
Andrew Noll a pallium valuable biologist
at Harvard another suspect a Dudley epic
of volcanic eruptions in Siberia thick
pulsating flows of glowing magma gushed
out of the numerous broad flat volcanoes
a geologist Paul Brennan of Berkeley geo
chronological Sen chronology son okay so
so so what are these people saying there
they all say it was all it all had to do
with some catastrophic accident that's
the only thing that these people could
think of they never thought about
biology they never thought about any
process of normal natural process it
they were all acts of God God or mother
nature or father univers one of those
guys up there right either through an
asteroid or came in with a supernova who
you know who zapped it it had to be a
catastrophic accident because they say
how can you explain jail geological
suddenness but the problem here is that
they explain geological suddenness with
a catastrophic accident or act of god
any way you want to call it but then
they cannot explain selectivity because
the issue here is that when you use an
asteroid you kill everything on earth as
you've seen that that's how they portray
it in documentaries though the whole
earth on fire the whole earth covered
with water and then would they have to
be like that if if an asteroid hits the
earth right in the big asteroid and it
causes all this debris to go all around
the earth and blot out the Sun and and
there's no more photosynthesis and
everything's on fire or everything's
under water which a water world you know
nothing is left alive and so the
question is how do you select how did
the mammal survive the dinosaurs how did
the arca stars come out out of you know
the dead synapses that died in the
Permian how did the synapses come out of
the you know out of the the amphibians
of the Carboniferous these guys died in
these guys these other guys continued
you gotta explain that selectivity how
one a group of animals died yet one
survived how some plants died and how
others survived you know it's very clear
that there was a time up to the
Carboniferous a little beyond the
Permian and even up to the Triassic you
had the firm's especially the seed firms
no longer exists and he seed ferns they
were dominant flora did it last forever
no the seed ferns went away and they
were replaced by the cycads and conifers
in general that's what the dinosaurs the
long
and all these other animals ate and then
we get to the era of you know our era
the mammals and the conifers are drawn
and so are the ferns II no longer
dominate the landscape what dominates
the landscape are the flowering plants
that we have today so we have these big
millions of years hundreds of millions
of years of one type of plant replaced
by another type of plant replaced by
another type of plant and you get these
animals used to these types of
vegetations they develop these symbiotic
relationships when they eat poop the you
know the seed and then another seed
grows up and it's last for millions of
years ideally you know finishes its
cycle and another plant Mother Nature
invents which is more versatile which is
more vibrant you know more advanced
replaces it very simple yeah and then
all we have to figure out is why plants
die all by themselves without asteroids
without volcanoes without supernovas
that's what we got to figure out then we
can explain selectivity because when the
plants go those animals go the ones who
have forged a relationship with those
plants and the new plants that come in
they have all these tiny animals that
suddenly irradiated become the new
dinosaurs the bigger animals right until
they juice of them and now you have
another one group of animals the mammals
which now follow the flowering plants so
on the basis of food we can explain it
very easily we can explain selectivity
not necessary to have volcanoes not
necessary to have catastrophic accidents
like asteroids and comets and supernovas
and all the nonsense that NASA is trying
to push for its own you know
self-interest okay so here we have a
paper seminal paper by the way 1971 Dale
Russell pretty important or famous
paleontologists for those who do
research
and he suggests in 1971 he said we wish
to suggest that a nearby supernova
explosion might produced climatic
effects so drastic as to cause the
extinction of many animals including
dinosaurs they were trying to propose
their theory that maybe it was you know
they come up with all these new ideas
the oh I'm gonna polish this and you
know NASA absolutely loves this this
fight between the supernova guys and the
asteroid guys and you know any other
extraterrestrial cause they absolutely
love it they D you know the in fact uh
you know here's a somewhere I have here
the paper all showed in a second NASA is
funding all these projects by the way
okay so that's important for you to know
okay uh here yes okay so you can see
who's behind it the gamma-ray that a
gamma-ray burst initiate late Ordovician
mass extinction okay and this is a group
of people who published this
what is it 2003 and if you see
underlined US National Science
Foundation and NASA oh those people love
this stuff they eat it they love it they
give all kinds of money you know tax
payers money to these guys to develop
these idiotic theories okay now you say
well why is it idiotic well here here
you see the here's the image so that you
can see what they're talking about okay
you have a gamma-ray hit the earth okay
what's that gamma-ray gonna do it's
gonna move a prize the air it's gonna
hit the air right out of the earth and
suddenly all these animals you know have
this period in which they have no air
and they died because they suffocate I
guess you know they have nothing to
breathe okay and you know when I look at
that I think of you know the cartoon
character foghorn leghorn
and here he is you know and foghorn you
know he's gonna get this child he's got
a babysit and he blows himself up and
all his feathers are gone and then the
next moment you know he recovers them
and that's more or less what these
people are saying they're saying you
know the the
Ordovician gamma-ray it wiped out the
birth get to the air of the earth and
somehow we recovered that here so it's
like you know the gamma-ray just hit
mother Gaia in the stomach she lost all
her air you know for a gasps for air for
a few moments then she recovered yeah so
again a lot of this these the mechanisms
these people proposed RTD on it they
have no place in science because they
cannot explain selectivity and the
mechanism itself is irrational I mean
gamma-ray just blows up all the air
right now assuming that happened right
and then how did we recover the air it's
just no hit in the stomach you lose your
hair and then you recover is that what
it is all the air just goes out into
space and then comes back in these
people are no longer rational they just
come up with theories to put their names
on the books and NASA loves this
propaganda they love it because it's in
their self-interest okay but see one of
the interesting things that you're gonna
see in all these cases is what I'm
telling you food think of food food food
food food food food chains one food
chain the old food chain disappears
because they're plant life the one they
depended on disappears new food chain
radiates okay a very simple process
natural process no catastrophic acts of
God are necessary and you say well is
that really true well it turns out that
all these catastrophic accidents are not
needed you can see that the common
denominator of all these theories is
food here you have the Albers pay this
is the Alvarez paper okay look at this
okay here's the Alvarez paper okay what
does Alberta say well he talks about
food chains of food chains collapsed
okay so he needs the asteroid but his he
says well how did they all these animals
disappear it was through the food chain
okay it was it was an issue of food
Indiana
okay and you say okay that's one maybe
here you have another group well this is
the same paper
okay just more elaborate okay here you
see I've underlined all the instances
that Alvarez talked about the food
chains and now they they were affected
okay and again he puts in there the the
fine printing animals that fed on
insects and decaying vegetation they
were able to survive so the food chains
disappeared but the asteroid did not
kill all the tiny animals because they
were able to treat us and you know dead
dead life or whatever okay here's a
another paper this is by Sheehan and
this is the another important
paleontology store or renown count
ologist and again he talks about food
chains that's what they all talk about
they say what happened was whatever
happened it affected the food chains
okay they can't live without the food
chains every theory has it in there the
food chain it's like they they say as an
afterthought like oh by the way you know
the food chains were affected we had the
Y asteroid we have the supernova we had
the volcanoes but Indiana what's it all
had to do with the food chain and and
this is the common denominator all these
theories okay it's the food chain and
here's another one this is for the
Permian this is out of the Wikipedia but
again that's a good starting point and
so what was the issue there well again
the food chain to collapse causing food
chains to collapse
okay that's whatever whatever causes it
in this case the Siberian traps Russian
volcanoes whatever it was we don't care
but the the point is that it ended up
affecting the food chain okay that's
that's the main point that all these
theories eventually end up with here's
another for the Permian another
representation another theory this is
again from that National Geographic
summary and again they talk about it
their short-term effects alone cold dark
an acid rain would kill plants and
photosynthetic plankton the base of most
food chains they have to make the food
chain disappear if they want to
especially if they want to explain
selectivity food chain is a very good
way of explaining selectivity and that
points to the fact that it's not the
trigger that we have to worry about it's
it's the fact that the food chain
disappears the whole an entire food
chain
okay here's the Ordovician again I like
to pick up on pick on these there's more
obviously but for lack of time I'm just
going to look at these three eras here's
the Ordovician extinction even modest 10
to 30 percent increases in UV flux
particularly around 300 nanometer can be
lethal to a variety of organisms name
but some references there
see also blah blah blah okay including
fiddle plankton the basis of the marine
food chain as well as oxygen production
so what do all these people say well
whatever cause that we don't care but
eventually we have to look at the food
chance the food chain that disappeared
okay and I showed the other day this
which is for the Cretaceous okay and you
can see what happened these animals were
disappearing already millions of years
before the end Cretaceous yeah so we
have to explain not like I gave the
example the other day where the where
the last where a big boulder kills the
last five Neanderthals you know that's
not we can't say well the reason the
dinosaur that the Neanderthals became
extinct is because of a rock okay
this is what these people are saying the
asteroid killed the dinosaurs the
dinosaurs were already disappearing in
the last few million years and of course
they had to read revise that and now the
theory has changed now they say well
that's not true they were expanding a
spending expense suddenly they died okay
and a question that was was there more
diversity
of dinosaurs that's one issue were there
more types of dinosaurs and why would
that be important well the plant life is
disappearing then you have fewer niches
into which to evolve and create new
species so if the plant life their plant
life is disappearing because of the
Cretaceous to rest your revolution where
you have the angiosperms this pushing
aside the gymnosperms well yeah if the
dinosaurs ate given those ferns and
they're their sources of food are
disappearing on the one hand and the
variety of sources of food are
disappearing you have fewer niches in
which to carve in which to make new
species okay so now don't need a number
of species reduces but also the number
of dinosaurs that can be supported by
the environment and that's an easier way
of visualizing how the dinosaurs
disappeared they belong to a given food
chain that had nothing to do with the
food change of routine of the mammals
which were dependent on the angiosperms
so so now we can see selectivity with
that okay okay anyways what did I
propose in exchange I'm saying that what
happened was this we had the overturning
of the ecological pyramid that's what
causes extinction you have it there
summarized in in this little picture
what happens is the plant life
disappears and so the herbivores have
fewer fewer varieties and fewer planets
also because they're being displaced by
the new vibrant plants that Mother
Nature has created in this case the
angiosperms replacing the gymnosperms
just like the gymnosperms they replaced
the ferns
okay that's important the show also how
the animals in the past like in the
Permian Triassic disappeared and of
course the Predators multiply and
herbivores become fewer and fewer
to feed all that population what you
have is essentially there's a ten to one
ratio between primary production and
herbivores and tend to one ratio between
herbivores and predators that's what is
known as a normal or healthy ecological
pyramid when it overturns we have an
unhealthy one and that leads to
extension that's the process that I'm
proposing okay now these are the
theories today that these people are
proposing for the extinction of man if
you want to get to the second stage
after you've finished extinction 101
then you can move into extinction 102
and here we have all these irrational
theories okay this is what people
believe in today 99% of humanity nuclear
or biological warfare these are the
possible extinction theories for man
right and nuclear biological warfare
absolutely not
we can very clearly say well we don't
throw the nukes we're done it's
avoidable see what I need is a foolproof
mechanism that's not a foolproof
mechanism that can be avoided by simply
not throwing the bombs and biological
warfare the same thing you know or if we
do not throw the biological weapons at
each other then we don't die so it's
very simple that's not what's going to
kill us
we need a guaranteed mekin as the one we
can't avoid no matter what that's what
we're looking for here we're looking for
the cookie cutter that killed the all
the other animals we want to apply it to
man and a cookie cutter I'm saying is
food food we we can deal with for the
animals and the question is whether
humans have any way of avoiding food ok
the starvation and I'm saying we can
there's no way absolutely no way that is
a guaranteed mechanism but I'll get to
that in a minute well probably next time
pandemic viruses bacteria all that stuff
absolutely not we we can looked at any
bug under the microscope kill it before
it kills us and no bug will kill all of
you man
it never has no no disease has ever
killed a species okay and all I can tell
you is after doing lots of research and
never happen any more than egg predation
ever killed the species another
ridiculous theory people come up with
just to put their names in the books
like oh I'm the first one who came up
with it okay
that's the only reason for those idiotic
theories climate change never killed the
species into the history of life on
Earth that's what for me it's ridiculous
all this hullabaloo about climate change
whether it's happening or not is
irrelevant in fact I think we probably
are contributing to climate change it's
very likely we're eight billion people
throwing all kinds of gasses in year
that might have some effect I don't know
I would think it does okay I'm saying
it's irrelevant never in the history of
life on Earth has climate change killed
a single species so all those people who
talk about climate change big problems
should see a psychiatrist okay
population declines through a preference
for fewer children yes but that's for
background extinction for each of a
single species okay geological disaster
never happened never will
volcanoes asteroids never happened never
will cosmological disasters save the
habitat threats overpopulation never
happened never will no species can
overpopulate no species get over
populate neither and humans cannot over
puppy in fact right now we're under
decline since 1963 that's what 56 years
now get the numbers right our population
has our birth rate has been declining
steadily not like in the 14th century
Black Plague for example from what is it
13:48 to 1350 to about four years Europe
was ravaged by the Black Plague like the
bubonic plague
and killed they say anywhere between a
third and a half of the population of
Europe and so people say oh you know a
disease can kill us and and you know you
have these this worry that unless
something like that happens again we're
gonna over populate the planet just
overflow just fall into space I guess I
don't know what these people have in
their in their minds no overpopulation
will never happen because women are not
having babies and they're not having
babies because they can't have babies
people think for women that have babies
is a freewill issue it's a deterministic
issue and again people say you're crazy
bill my girlfriend is pregnant you know
she it was freewill you know no no you
didn't listen correctly I didn't say
woman I said women plural women is a
deterministic process women cannot have
on the average babies anymore and
there's nothing we can do about it
that's the worst part the reason we're
not having babies has nothing to do or
very little to do really with NGOs you
know all these government organizations
that go out there tell the especially
the black poor women don't have babies
you don't have money to support the blah
blah blah and they say ah see though
it's working we're having fewer babies
and then the Chinese impose the you know
one child per family and so on it's
gotten really nothing to do with it the
reason we're not having babies as we
went from the country to the cities you
can't have babies in the cities and it
happens to all species when when the
bacteria get on the bread and they start
multiplying and they formed our cities
at some point they stopped reproducing
they can't continue expanding forever on
the bread okay and that's what's
happened we went from the country to the
cities we have mega cities and the
country is in the hands of agricultural
corporations which produce the food that
feeds the cities that's that's how we
evolved and it was
predictable that we would have evolved
in that direction now we are in these
big cities we have millions of people in
there half of them without jobs and and
what happens the food comes from the
country and when you're in the city and
you don't have any money and and there's
the oldest crowdedness and you're in a
little apartment you can't have ten
children an apartment for some reason I
don't know why you'd imagine ten
children your one-bedroom apartment
never happened never will so women will
not have children from now on it's
impossible
there's nothing humans can do by the no
technology no intelligence no foresight
can overturn that that trend so we're on
the path to extinction if it weren't for
mass extinction we would have a single
species a background accenture humans
would die out all by themselves without
the help of a mass extinction
fortunately that mass extinction happens
earlier and spares us the agony of dying
like the nanda calls in a slow
progressive way okay anyways habitat
threats overpopulation never happened
never will never populate the entire
earth it'll never happen we're gonna die
in the cities that exist today we're not
going to found any new cities you know
people think that we're gonna go out in
the middle of the desert sahara desert
found some 10 million people city
population no way never gonna happen
whatever cities we have on the planet
today that's how we die we're not gonna
invent new cities okay and you know the
colonization is over sunning boasts the
earth yeah that will happen in the
future don't wait for it okay super
intelligent entity annihilates as we
create this this robot and he takes over
because he's more intelligent than us
you know and that causes our extinction
because they don't need us now okay
uncontrolled the nanotechnology destroys
ecosystem ecosystems not going to change
anything creation of a micro black hole
total idiocy nonsense poppycock okay
invasion by military superior
look at the theories they say I'm the
first one to come up with it you know
it's just to put their names in the
books it's idiocy these are not
extinction this is just person who's
trying to brainstorm some poppycock
there and just throws it in there and
these are all in in the Wikipedia of
course you won't find a food my theory
you won't find it in their theories that
have a chance to officially that can
threaten the existing theories
especially NASA's catastrophic theories
you'll never find them in any formal you
know medium those who will not see but
you will see all this nonsense about
many black calls and you know the
superior Klingons who come and kill us
all you know that stuff you'll find a
lot of that stuff they don't care about
that stuff because then it doesn't
threaten anything that they've got okay
and in the posthuman you know we we
simply make so many changes in our
bodies that were no longer human we're
we're no longer you know what we used to
be just blood and skin and muscle no
it's a now you're metal and wires and
who knows what else yeah and let's see
I've got one more what is it uh where is
it here it is these are problems that
humans cannot solve so if you get a
theory along these lines you you'll know
where I'm gonna come at you what my car
no arguments gonna be on you okay these
are things humans cannot do anything
about with other intelligence and
foresight in technology we cannot have
babies anymore okay that's the first one
well babies are over it's a women are
not gonna have babies in the future okay
we're already there
we're not having babies the birth rate
has been steadily declining it was that
it was that when a 2.3 in 1963 that was
the last high point since that we've
been dropping and today we've got were
closer to one and by you know century by
really by mid century by 2050 were
supposed to be reaching zero population
growth in other words the birth rate
drop down to zero okay
eliminating wealth pyramid there's no
way we can do that we're always going to
have this pyramid no matter whether you
do communism anarchism
anarcho-capitalism you whatever the
system you got in your mind that's never
gonna change
there's always gonna be a pyramid okay
increasing genetic diversity we have no
way of increasing our genetic diversity
we can only lose it from now on and
we've been losing it today we have no
genetic diversity practically none in
the human race and there's a couple
articles on that out there we can't
avoid growing old we can't avoid
individual death your personal death you
know sometimes I wanted me to see how
I'm dressed for the occasion today
that's why I'm so dark oh you got to
talk about extra how should I dress I
should burst flirt I was wondering you
know what the what is it the Grim Reaper
looks like I mean is he green is he
black and if he's black I hope I hope
he's not racist I mean you know I don't
want to take the blame for all the Aryan
problems in the past
with blacks okay please keep me out of
that one right okay overturning on the
population pyramid we have no way
avoiding at our population pyramid has
begun to overturn in 1963 we cannot do
anything about that with all our
intelligence all our technology all our
force say we can't fix that problem we
can't travel to the future to the Past
like the relativist think in fact that's
how I got into this there these into
extinction people because of general
relativity people say the mathematicians
and they all believe that we're going to
go out into space and conquer or first
Mars and then out into a solar se the
nearest star system could be Alpha
Centauri apparently you I think it's
beta Centauri has a similar build as our
solar system only only data because you
got alpha beta and alpha beta and and
what's the other one and Proxima and
it's a three star system one of those
stars is more like our Sun and so
there's this
hope that maybe it's got planets rolling
around it like here on our solar system
and we would be able to lure down there
if we ever make it down there so they
have all these ideas of how to get out
there into space at the anisa to linear
star which is a 4.3 light years away
traveling at the speed of light it takes
you four point three years to get there
one way okay and anyways and that's
traveling at the speed of light that's
the nearest star and so we have no
chance of getting out there but you know
I used to think that we could that in
fact I got all out of this from Carl
Sagan you know he hypnotized me he was a
pretty good teacher right but he taught
nonsense it just took me a while to
figure it out you know all of what Carl
Sagan said it's just garbage we're going
to contact another civilization that
we're going to go out into space and
conquer the the near stars and then the
galaxies it's all it's all wishful
thinking it's got nothing to do with the
reality we're never going out there
we're never even going to colonize Mars
we're not gonna terraform Mars all that
stuff you talked about we're not even
going to colonize the moon we're all
going to die here on earth very soon in
fact okay so other stuff absolutely
nonsense and the extinction of the human
race we can't avoid that as well
overturning of the ecological pyramid
which is what a mass extinction is about
the fact that we have food disappears
food disappears because we produce it
with money and I'm gonna argue next time
is money there's gonna be no more that's
that's the mechanism mechanism is money
is no more our economy collapses this
integrates completely not a depression
not a recession total annihilation of
money money you will not accept money
like you don't accept Vietnamese money
today and you know if you're living the
States or here in Europe someone came in
to even try to pay you with Vietnamese
money you'd say what can I do with that
I can't accept that and that's more or
less what money is gonna become you're
not gonna accept money because money
first of all it's disappearing all by
itself is becoming
all this abstract money it's it's all a
number in the computer it's not even it
used to be gold and it's used to be
these paper you know IOUs and so on we
turn that into paper money then money
now is disappearing and now we have all
this electronic money now we have all
these bitcoins and so on so it's already
quite abstract and it turns out that
that abstraction keeps us alive in
thanks to that abstraction think about
that for a second you haven't before
killing me and hanging me you know in
the park think about it for a second
this abstraction keeps us alive thanks
to that abstraction we call money which
is faith only faith that's the reason we
produce food for all and distributed to
all of humanity think about that for a
second in fact think about it until
until Wednesday what I will see you
again okay and I'll look at the
questions that the comments that were
made and if there's something
interesting I'll comment on it next time
okay but next time I'll talk about money
and a human economy and the only once
again let's see if I can put that back
up here if I can find it got so many of
these sometimes what you have to do is
here I think it's this one let's see
what you have to do is this is your
homework okay if you're going to put a
comment if you put a question first I
want you to talk about extinction not
about human extinction I don't want you
to tell me all how how great you are in
economics and how much you know about
politics and so on we don't care to
listen about it what you get explain is
how animals in the past night show that
you're an expert in extinction that you
take an extinction 101 if you don't know
about extinction if you don't know the
causes
the mechanisms of extinction of the
dinosaurs of the arca stars of the
synapses of the amphibians if you don't
know anything about that you know
nothing about extinction you are an
ignoramus so don't talk about human
extinction don't put a comment they'll
put a question because you don't know
anything about extinction first learn
extinction then you can move to human
extinction okay and and then yeah then
you can talk about human extinction if
you passed the you know you passed the
course extinction 101 then you can take
extinction 102 you can go into human
extinction show me or show the audience
you know crowd your uh you know those
three questions will humans ever die if
not why are we going to continue living
if so how will man becoming sane what
will kill us and I need a foolproof
mekin as a guaranteed Mecca something at
you know I want you to win the race with
your horse I don't want you saying well
maybe we can throw the bombs at each
other or maybe there's a disease at all
nano none of that okay you gotta have a
foolproof guaranteed mechanism if you
cannot come up with a foolproof
guaranteed mechanism you know nothing
about human extinction we'll see you on
Wednesday
and I hope I pissed off half the crowd
out there
we'll see how worthy bye-bye